now before we dive any further with this
video I just wanted to take a minute to
acknowledge the fact of how crazy things
have been in the world right now if
you're in self-isolation or and complete
lockdown please make sure you listen to
your local authorities and your local
governments I am NOT a healthcare
professional I know very little about
the pandemic and I know even less about
what's happening around the rest of the
world so for me I will personally take
no stand on social media whatsoever
about what is going on I will keep my
opinions to myself and I will make sure
to stay up to date with the information
released by the Australian government as
much as I can because at the moment that
is unfortunately all that we can do as
individuals but together we will get
through this so please stay safe and
enjoy the rest of this video
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is Dave
homage and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about an epic battle
between the Samsung s20 ultra and the
king of b-roll the DSLR now at the end
of this video I will also have a
giveaway update which is in relation to
my last video if it's something you want
to check out make sure you jump towards
the end of the video it will be there so
the reason this whole b-roll battle
would actually came about is because my
car is absolutely filthy at the moment
and fortunately for us the state of
Western Australia has as of the moment
I'm recording this not going into
lockdown or enforce any major rules as a
result of the current conditions I was
able to go out so I'd take my car to the
car wash and film an epic b-roll battle
because as you guys know in my last
video I tested the s20 ultra against the
big DSLR for the sole reason that I
personally want to get rid of my DSLR
and focus on some mobile content
creation now being a very logical person
being very focused on the facts and the
figures I want to make sure that the
content I produce is just as good on the
mobile if not better
so from here on in I wanted to create a
very similar sequence of events a very
similar b-roll that I could compare for
myself and then provide information to
you guys which one's better what are the
key factors one of the key faults and
how we could overcome them with a big
DSLR or with a very light mobile device
so I'm going to play two clips for you
guys now that have been edited in a very
similar sequence one is the s20 ultra
and the
that is the DSLR let me know down in the
comments below if you think number one
or number two is the s20 ultra
[Music]
okay so both of those clips are
incredibly similar for some facts and
figures s20 ultra was used on 4k video
recording mode at 30 frames per second
the DSLR on the other hand was filmed at
720p at 60 frames a second because that
is the maximum my camera can film at at
60 frames a second and I like to slow it
might be roll down now if you're a video
guy you're gonna know which clip was
which from that information alone what I
had figured out later down the track is
you can use the s20 ultra in 4k 60
frames a second which is incredible you
can also use it at 1080p at 240 frames a
second and slow it down to 120 frames a
second at 1080p now with that
information I've created it one more
clip with a little bit of the s20 and a
little bit of the DSLR salt and peppered
throughout with a little keynote
underneath that lets you guys know which
one is which and try to really figure
out if there is that much of a
difference
[Music]
now I want to point out the fact that
both of these clips were handheld
neither of them had a gimbal neither of
them had a tripod or a gorilla pod they
were literally handheld throughout the
whole clip that's why there's a little
bit of shaking a little bit of warp
stabilization to bring it back into high
quality the way I like it
but for handheld both devices came out
pretty good so when you match these
clips together the footage actually
comes out really really good and the
color grading on both of these is very
similar the color grade I put on to the
first clip which was the s20 ultra if
you'll play the guessing game was very
very similar to the color grade I put on
top of the second clip which was the
DSLR the only difference there was a
little bit of temperature control and
adjusting the hue and saturation the
DSLR was a little bit too green so I had
to bump up the Purple's to get that blue
cinematic effect and I made the setting
of putting the DSLR at 6300 kelvins
instead of 5a so I had to bring those
temperature controls right back down to
balance it out again however the
differences for the rest of that color
grade were absolutely nil there was no
additional contrast for the s20 ultra
over the DSLR there was no additional
saturation no additional as shadows or
highlight blasting it was pretty much
identical top-to-toe now considering the
fact that my camera is set to a very
neutral color profile as close to C log
as you can get on a Canon 6d versus the
s20 ultra which films in a very I want
to say ready to use format it's color
graded basically from the start it's
very surprising that the color grade is
near identical the one thing that I did
notice is the fact that the DSLR isn't
stabilized in any way
perform there's no in body there's no
ill ends there's nothing on my DSLR
where is the s20 ultra obviously has
super steady video recording which still
isn't perfect I would suggest having a
gimbal if you're really running around
and doing some crazy cinematic stuff but
from a handheld point of view it held up
so much better as it was very made
evident in my last video just comparing
all the features of the s20 best DSLR
when we compare the two clips there
isn't that much of a difference which is
fantastic news for me considering my
choice to purchase this device it is
interesting to note that the bokeh on
the DSLR is still much much better
obviously there's a lot more depth of
field and there is a lot more glass so
you're gonna get a higher quality more
professional image but this can be faked
in the s20 ultra if you want to fake it
in post-production it just takes a
little bit more time you'll notice that
in one of the clips on the s20 ultra you
can see the car in the background very
slightly towards the end and most of it
is relatively sharp whereas on the DSLR
that car is completely blown out and
bokeh and it's nice and buttery soft so
that is the only difference personally
that I could pick up in those two clips
from a recording point of view I think
the fact that colour grades are very
similar the way you edit is very similar
the nature of the files is very very
similar and the fact that super study is
on the s20 ultra makes it a perfect
device for video recording in any
setting that you need now I will be
putting this camera through its paces in
a whole bunch of different tests so if
there's anything specific you want to
know let me know in the comments down
below and I will test it as best as I
can now before we end this video I
wanted to make a quick giveaway update
on my last video I announce I'm gonna be
doing a pretty big giveaway what I found
is that people will pay no attention to
what I say in this video so I want to
clarify this and make sure people
understand I have no
giving away the s20 ultra I'm not giving
away my DSLR I am giving away a set of
galaxy Plus headphones which you
received with the s20 ultra they are
being shipped to me directly and should
arrive within the next week so in that
video I stated the competition will run
for four to six weeks that's all for me
guys thank you so much for joining me if
you enjoyed the video make sure you
smash that subscribe button
20:20 style and as always I'll see you
next Monday